I mean now it's not the time for us to
meet see you soon now's not the time
no fun oh no that broke I'll hold it on
the broker ah what well you don't know
how to fly it an airplane a helicopter
why did you pick a helicopter if you
didn't know how to fly it an airplane a
[ __ ] airplane god I'm an idiot sorry
zombie apocalypses wait zombie
apocalypse some Aiza Zambia Oh then free
oh yeah sure oh my figure figured I was
there it is yours oh thanks this thing
or this thing no this thing oh yeah this
thing this thing this this thing okay
stop fighting me area this thing
what's kind of you worth a fortune on
the black market but aggressive of
theorem even of the most aggressive of
theoretical scenarios even if even
inside the most restrictive there's
theoretical scenarios oh do you still
have the back of the box give the box as
you know I'm so sorry
I feel this okay that's better
all right
[Music]
I've done all the calculations the math
checks out but yeah I thought you were
scientist not a mathematician goodbye no
[Laughter]
limited power you gotta go drunk on the
power and either way what do you say
let's save the world yes let's save the
world goodbye I'm moving my friend
including my friends they'll be fine I
think
you piece of [ __ ]
I hate you no one watch you
this way come on in here I don't think
any of this was supposed to happen
and I'm not just talking about you have
a zombie apocalypse
huh
[Music]
yeah okay so I'm gonna ask you this just
oh no me map no no well that's a relief
if you'd known even a single thing -
[Music]
well buddy what do you think you want to
go first or should I oh I'm pretty
hungry chairs waiting friends cheers you
know how much I love sitting oh it's so
comfortable - oh my bed is it it's a
cushioned home just you wait I'm waiting
if this man would make a choice man the
person of indistinguishable gender here
we go it's a spectrum definitely
different islands that can't read what
am i doing please tell me that wasn't
the sound of you hitting the Orcas
lasers the homeless bombardment homies
thank its orbital laser bombardment
homing beacon three two one that's my
beautiful hats how about we reset that
now would be the time did you say words
correctly yoo-hoo
speaking of service no no no no no no no
you all right
you have enough sea stroke you haven't a
sea spasm no back to work we aren't so
different after all
you think oh no lines not to be crossed
to intercept you snooze you lose pal
look I like how that looks looks like
look like that's probably fine yeah okay
[Music]
let me give you a hand with that
since the sail drop anchor how do you
guys mean you never dig a hole before
[Music]
[Laughter]
my dream how could you betray me like
this
oh how good how good you betray me like
this I'm a federal marshal you
undercover [ __ ] I'm so good I mean it's
been a few years but I could just like I
bet I'm thinking probably kill you and
your whole family
Oh your liver no you won't Oh will you
could put me in jail no way of course
I'm not look at these then some digging
arms you better drop your weapons and
surrender oh I don't think so this thing
can't be dropped once spent picked up
it's not attached to you you could
definitely drop just lay down
careful it's like an honor thing I have
to use it once it's been exposed said it
was set right next to you before set it
back where it was
look at this so watch out drop your
weapons Shinde do you know what that
means
no well forget it you just best to
forget you just do this justice just
used it just best to forget about those
familial bonds who uses things bad and
they'll always be bad I'm sorry
I don't know why I'm hammering on that
line so much means you're already dead
I mean events yeah okay call my bluff I
can see the gears turning in your head
and you're thinking oh you bet think
right don't think wrong I feel like this
should have reached a resolution at some
point here bang I don't belong in here
you might belong in here with all this
[Music]
come on let's get an awkward
uncomfortable just standing here
everyone look in there don't make me
look bad in some voice yeah I saw they
came out of me no no you can still
survive you can make it out don't throw
your life away and then we fall right so
what's it gonna be you gonna stick with
us of us come stiffness free
oh it was okay the whole time look at
what you're alive yeah I didn't have a
scene the other chick but uh which way
do you think to go partner
right or left dark or light which which
way which way is good which way you
wanna go
you won't go this way or you won't go
that way either good choice come on you
can pick you pick this way or you pick
that way
[Music]
who is it this do one we can feel it in
my bones
Thank You 12 coming don't you have
planes gone
hey feeling up the awesome great it's
surprisingly comfortable is the
ice-cream mark boy we do what it takes
every day all day
you would go never mind we're not going
just kidding
[Music]
big deep you know we hope for the best
you dare no time like the present
[Music]
are we still rolling okay all right
you're go but that's all I'm going to
give you